[Musique]
il y a du reste un critérium du moment
un critérium immédiate de cette
indépendance
cela est dans le domaine atomique il
s'agit de savoir si pendant que les
autres se sont fait continue de se faire
des armes capables de détruire l'univers
et nous aussi
il s'agit de savoir si nous aurons aussi
nous n'aurons pas nous aussi de quoi
nous défendre
nous avons décidé d'avoir ce qu'il nous
faut et d'autant mieux est d'autant plus
que cette puissance nucléaire comme on
dit est liée directement à
l'énergie atomique elle même qui est
comme vous le savez tous
le font de l'activité de demain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]